[Music]
you're looking great thank you yeah
ginger magic yes always been a ginger do
you like being a ginger I do but we're a
dying breed apparently yes I keep
hearing that we should mate to save the
species why are you backing off right
away okay yeah we you know so much type
of first of all I saw you and your
husband Sacha Baron Cohen yes like a
couple of weeks ago I was out at a
restaurant and I run into you too yes
and that's never happened before I don't
go out a lot no we don't either and I go
out and I see you I run right into you
guys we start chatting and then I think
you mentioned something about how you're
sure sometimes embarrassed to go out
with seems like such a funny guy why I
got to be honest Conan there are a lot
of social faux pas I mean when we first
came to Hollywood we went to this film
premiere that Jack Black you know was
producing a movie and invited us and we
arrived and this lady stood up and made
a really long speech she was a biggish
lady in her 60s and then Jack Black got
up and made a short speech and we
watched the whole film and afterwards we
were congratulating him and you know
Jack back said yeah if I'd known the
movie was gonna be so great I would have
made a longer speech
I mean sash I said yeah like that woman
who wouldn't shut up with the massive
boobs and then Jack said that was my mom
well big boobs are great Isla wants big
boobs you you want big boobs right babe
I was saying it was just work he's
digging the hole deeper deeper and
deeper and also he's someone who
professionally probably doesn't he
doesn't feel embarrassment the way the
rest of us do no he really doesn't yeah
he really doesn't so he's gonna finish
you in this town yeah he really has
already you've got this film of
Bachelorette